PRITHPAL BHOGILL:
Thank you, Kelsey.
So in this session,
we're going to talk
about a few key concepts.
We'll touch on API management
for serverless and multi-cloud.
So my name's Prithpal Bhogill.
I'll be the co-host of the
session for the next 50
minutes.
And we'll try and make it
interactive and interesting.
So I'm part of the
Apigee product team.
I drive a few different
areas for the Apigee team
for the core platform.
And then I'm also today going
to be joined by my partner
in crime, Kelsey
Hightower, who's
going to come in and actually
show stuff in action.
So just a quick show of
hands, how many developers
in the audience?
Excellent.
How about serverless?
How many folks working
with serverless?
OK.
And just one last question.
How many folks out here are
using multiple clouds today?
OK.
Just look around, quite a few.
Keep your hands up for a
second if you guys can.
Look around.
OK, excellent.
Awesome.
So then you can be
the right session.
So let's start with some
housekeeping rules here
real quick.
So this time at Next, we
are doing Q&A a little bit
differently.
We have a couple of
mics here in the middle.
So you're more than
welcome to line up
towards the end of the
session for questions.
But if not, you can also
use the Cloud Next app.
Click on the Dorie Q&A,
and ask any questions out
there as well.
And towards the
end of the session,
we will just read
off those questions,
and just take our shot at
answering it as you go along.
Awesome.
So let's spend a
few minutes talking
a little bit about serverless.
As I go spend time
with many developers,
they are adopting serverless
at their own pace.
But there are key
entities from serverless,
which make it very attractive.
The first one is the aspect
of completely abstracting away
the underlying infrastructure.
So developers love to code.
And they want to really
just deal with code
and say, here's my code.
Just go make it happen.
Just go run it for me.
Obviously, there's some
other business benefits
to be ascertained from that
as well, such as agility.
Because you're working
with code as a construct,
and you are not worrying
about infrastructure,
assuming a provider can manage
that for you, you become more
faster rolling out
capabilities, which
are more differentiated
for your business,
and gain competitive advantage.
Productivity is another
key aspect of it.
Because you can do
that faster, you
have multiple teams who
can collaborate and build
capabilities at a
much faster pace.
So serverless is
obviously catching up
as you saw today
with a show of hands.
A lot of folks are
looking at serverless
as the next style
of architecture
in building newer
modern capabilities.
And microservices kind
of goes hand in hand
with serverless in a big way.
Usually when folks are
refactoring the applications
from monolith into smaller
microservices, many of them
are choosing serverless as
the key architecture style
to build those applications.
And clearly, we have seen a
big evolution in serverless.
When serverless here the
stage a few years back,
it was all about
functions, or also known
as functions as a service.
Clearly, there's been an
evolution from functions
to building full-blown apps, and
now to serverless containers.
Of course, Google Cloud has
capabilities no matter which
serverless flavor you pick.
But this brings a
very important element
of choice, which
is no matter what
style you pick, you have
the ability in Google Cloud
today to be able to
leverage the specific flavor
and create application to
power some awesome experiences.
Just like the
internet happened, we
believe that developers
have a choice.
They're going to use
various frameworks for very
obvious productivity gains.
And so trying to control
which framework they use
doesn't really work out.
Because they have
a choice, you want
to empower developers and make
sure they have all the access
and controls to be able to
use a framework of choice.
But of course, as
an organization,
you also want to be
able to put some method,
put some control around it, so
you can manage it very well.
But the reality is developers
are using many underlying
frameworks-- some of these
which are mentioned here--
to build new
capabilities, but more so
are increasingly doing
that on different clouds.
Just like yourselves,
many customers
are choosing different
clouds for various reasons.
It could be diversifying risk.
It could be some cloud has
some capabilities better
than the others, right?
What I want to do now is kind
of poke a little bit deeper
into what we believe are
some of the key differences
between a service.
So at the end of
the day, when you're
building a serverless
application,
you are delivering a service--
service of some
value to something.
So let's say it's
a piece of code,
a snippet, or the entire runtime
as we just saw in a container--
the other spectrum of
the serverless flavor.
Let's say you write
something in there.
Let's pick an example
of an ordering system.
OK.
So you have a small service
that can take orders.
That microservice is
an architecture style.
That's your backend,
if you would.
That's what you are writing
in terms of business logic,
as your code as a developer.
Now, the moment that service
gets pushed out to a consumer--
so someone who starts
to access that service--
that becomes an API.
So an API is a contract.
This is the front-end of how
a service is usually accessed.
In many instances,
these two concepts
are assumed to be
implicitly together.
So as an example,
when you roll out
some piece of serverless
capability, of course
it has an endpoint.
But there's a clean
line of separation.
And we'll explain why
it is the way it is.
As you start to examine
how folks are refactoring
into a newer modern
applications,
well, it turns out there were
legacy applications on one
of the applications
which existed before.
It turns out they were
consumers who are still
using those applications.
So those consumers
are still using
an API, which is a contract
into an application.
The difference is
now you've kind
of migrated or to new serverless
style of building applications.
So your backend
has really changed.
It's very important
to understand
the semantic difference
between a service and an API.
And we'll touch on
that a little bit more.
So why does that matter?
At the end of the
day, enterprises
are building
serverless applications
to eventually power
digital experiences.
You heard Thomas
talk this morning
about digital transformation.
What does digital
transformation really mean?
It means that in
this day and age,
enterprises are building
digital products without nothing
but APIs.
So API has become
the new mechanism
to express capabilities
for businesses.
And these APIs, which
power these connected data
experiences-- whether
that is powering
an app that is used
by your employees,
or a third-party partner,
or essentially building
an ecosystem of
different experiences,
it are these APIs
that really start
to take the value that
you're building in serverless
and make it accessible
to consumers.
So let's take a step
up and say, well great,
I have built some capabilities.
How do I really manage this?
Turns out the moment you build
some stuff, which can easily
be accessed, the very
first thing and you
start thinking about
is security, right?
Is this serverless capability
that I built, is it
being accessed by
someone who really
has the rights to
access, or is authorized
to access that capability?
Right?
Can I control it from making
sure that it is not abused?
Of course, serverless is going
to give you endless scalability
behind the scenes for you.
But you still want to be able
to ensure what if there's
a business quota to it?
What if you have signed
up for the service,
and you're really
only allowed to use
that 1,000 times a minute?
Because maybe I'm offering
a different tier or service,
and one partner gets more
fair share than the other,
based on a subscription plan.
That the other aspect
that we get into
is, great, how do developers
and consumers of serverless--
how do they really
find out about
your serverless applications?
Is there a mechanism for them
to discover them somewhere?
And lastly, for the enterprise,
it's also about great,
we took this big effort of
refactoring our monolith
and legacy applications into
modern, serverless style apps.
How do we know people
are using them?
Is there an adoption?
What is my ROI?
These are some very
hard questions,
which technical teams have
to answer to the businesses,
because someone is making
an investment in that.
Turns out there is a way
to answer these questions.
So an API management
platform brings a lot
of these capabilities
out of the box,
so you as enterprises
can continue
focusing on building
business logic,
writing code in serverless
style development paradigms,
yet have the peace of mind
around how you can use an API
management platform--
like Apigee Edge-- to be
able to control access
to your servers apps, provide
the right level of security,
also provide the ability for
your serverless applications
to be discovered easily, so
that application developers who
are consuming our
serverless apps
can very quickly
connect with them,
work with them, and then more
importantly as an enterprise,
use some key dashboards, which
give you a sense of adoption
metrics, operational metrics
because all those things are
very important.
OK.
So now let's take a
slightly deeper dive
into what does API management
for serverless actually mean.
For today, in this
session, we are
going to very quickly
demonstrate some real world
capabilities using Google
Cloud technologies, including
Apigee Edge.
But let's spend a couple
of minutes on this slide.
So it turns out
when developers take
on decomposing a big
monolith application,
the goal is to be able
to separate them out
into discrete and
independent usable serverless
apps or chunks.
Which means there's
always a need
to take a bunch of these
serverless applications
and compose them into
something more meaningful.
So I spoke very briefly about
the connected experiences
that you're trying to deliver.
Ultimately, whatever
you're building
the serverless is powering
some experience to a consumer.
So turns out there are multiple
ways and multiple design
patterns that you need to
be able to adopt to access
these capabilities,
which are now
scattered across in
multiple functions, or apps,
or even containers.
So an API gateway--
which is part of the API
management platform--
starts to take a very central
role in giving you the tools
and widgets to be able to not
only protect your serverless
applications, but
more importantly,
take data from several
of them, compose them
into a higher level experience
API, and deliver that.
And in doing that, you can
use a lot of capability
from the API management
platform such as ensuring
the right level of security,
right level of access,
and the ability for you to make
some transformations for them.
OK.
So with that, I would
like to invite my partner
in crime, Kelsey.
Give him a big hand.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
don't have any slides.
Hope that's cool.
So this morning, you
heard about Cloud Run.
Anyone use Cloud Run yet?
Like one person.
You work at Google?
OK.
We have the check.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to talk about this kind of
from the practitioner level.
What's happening now, I
guess, if you strip away all
the buzzwords-- serverless,
multi-cloud, all the noise--
you just have more
tools to build whatever
you need to build and ship it.
So we'll start with Cloud Run.
It's kind of this
serverless runtime
we have from Google Cloud.
My foray into the
serverless world,
I liked the idea of these
functions and these code
snippets.
But there are some
times where I just
really need to write the app in
a way that I'm familiar with.
Some of the frameworks helps.
Sometimes it doesn't.
So in the case of Cloud
Run, I can basically
build an app in any language I
want, build a Docker container,
push it to a registry,
and then deploy it.
If you've never seen
Cloud Run in action,
I'll show you a little bit now.
So I have a couple of things
that we're going to deploy.
We're going to step
to this one by one.
So Cloud Run is really
straightforward.
What you have here's a
very simple application.
Let's do this.
So this is just a go app.
It's really simple.
And the goal of this
whole serverless paradigm
is you're supposed to focus
on the business logic, right?
So you're not going to have
a lot of things like retries.
You're not going to do
any of your typical things
that you would do with Nginx.
You're not going
to put that here.
You're going to just kind of
focus on the business logic.
Today, my business logic is
just reporting the runtime
that I'm using.
I want you to focus on
the overall architecture,
not necessarily what
this app is doing.
So when I deployed
this container,
it's just going to
respond Cloud Run.
The reason why I like this
particular paradigm is I
like to be able to develop
locally on my laptop
using common tools.
So if I say go build,
what I'm expecting
is that I can actually test
this particular runtime
on my local machine.
And if I wanted to, I should
be able to hit this with Curl
using the familiar process
that I've been using for years.
Most of this stuff is data
comes in, data goes out.
It shouldn't be
that complicated.
You can see here that
I hit it with Curl,
and it says Cloud Run.
This could be any
runtime, any language.
We don't care.
It's just going to
make some system calls.
You're going to get
an HTTP request,
and you're going to respond.
So the way we deploy this
is with a Docker file.
So if you've used Docker
before, a very similar pattern.
I don't care what
you doing here.
You're going to end up with some
container image with some entry
point.
I'm using a two-step
build just to make
this container super small.
There's a lot of people in
the serverless community that
hear containers, and then
instantly just like catch fire.
I'm like, it's a
packaging format.
You can ship source code.
You can ship a binary.
And this is just
another mechanism
for shipping a binary.
So if you look here
in my two-part build,
the only thing I'm shipping
is this small binary here.
And I'm throwing
away everything else.
OK.
So this just gives
me that flexibility
of deploying what I want
in my own container image.
Then you ask yourself, how do
I actually deploy this thing?
So you can build this
thing using Cloud Build.
I don't actually have Docker
installed on my laptop anymore
these days because I use a
tool we call Cloud Build.
And what I can do is I
can submit my source code
and that Docker file, and
it will just build it here
from my laptop.
Or I can use the CI/CD flow,
and it will just do it for me.
But the idea is we want to make
this as simple as possible.
Some of our IDE plugins, this
will be automate it for you.
So you hit Save,
it will do a build.
And then how do you deploy
it to Cloud Run itself?
We also want that to
be straightforward.
So if you look at my
display command, that's it.
The nice thing about
this particular pattern
is if you already have
a container running
on Docker, or on
Kubernetes, and you
want to get rid of
the cluster, you
the infrastructure,
you just run this one command.
Tell us what the image
is, and we'll deploy it
and run it for you in
that serverless style.
We scale to zero, and we
scale up on the request
when it comes.
So when we run this command,
what you end up getting
is a URL.
So we'll click over here.
So this is what the
Cloud Run URL looks like.
We also mentioned in the keynote
earlier that in Cloud Run,
you can also bring your
own Kubernetes cluster.
So if you're on-prem--
maybe you're already using GKE.
You have a collection
of workloads,
and you just want to use that
serverless style, that service
pattern--
you can run these side by side.
You can actually say, G Cloud,
deploy to this GKE cluster,
and it will show up
in the same console.
So you can kind mix
and match if you really
need access to like a GPU
or some specialized hardware
that we don't do on the
stateless service platform
here.
So here's our thing.
It's called Runtime.
And it comes with the URL
and Talis certificate.
You can also map a
custom domain to it.
But we're just going to
keep it really simple.
One thing that we've done
is you don't necessarily
need to use an API
gateway day one.
You can just hit this
particular endpoint.
And in my case, this
is a private function.
So if you authenticate to
it, then you'll be charged.
If you do not authenticate
to this endpoint,
you won't be charged, and your
function will never be invoked.
OK.
So that's an
important thing here.
So we'll copy and paste this.
I'm just going to run
Curl on my local machine.
And we get this 403.
And the reason why is that
I don't want people hitting
this container directly.
I actually want to go through
some proxy or some gateway.
And this is where this
Apigee piece comes in.
As a developer, what
I want to focus on
is just that business
logic, and then
deploy my endpoints
wherever that may be.
So the first I want
to do is say, hey,
instead of me configure
authentication here in my app,
we're going to delegate
that to Apigee.
Now, I'm pretty new
to Apigee myself.
So last year, I built
a bunch of hacks
to create OAuth tokens to store
in Apigee's key value store,
and then tell Apigee to pull
it out, put it in a header,
called my code.
I was like, this is terrible.
I call the Apigee team.
I was like, there's no way
we work at the same company
and I have to do these
kind of workarounds.
So they built some
extensions for me.
I was like, let me see them.
Do they work?
That's what you always
ask your product team.
Does it work?
They always say yeah
for some reason.
So to think about
this is there's
a new set of things
called extensions.
And what you do is you
find one of the extensions.
So in this case, I want
basically our Google auth
extension.
And what the Google
auth the extension does
is the Google auth
extension will
allow me to use OAuth token or
admit one for me automatically.
Let me go through this.
This is off.
So here I just
called it Cloud Run,
but it's using the Google
authentication extension.
And what this does
is I can configured
this particular extension
with a service account,
and tell it what it's
going to be used for.
So if you click here,
you'll be given the ability
to configure this and deploy
it to one of your Apigee
environments.
So I basically have
a set of credentials
that we don't show
you on the screen.
I'm glad because
that would be bad.
And then basically at this
point this particular extension
using that service
account can then
be referenced when
I create a proxy.
So if you're new to Apigee--
like I am--
I'm going to walk you through a
little bit of what this means.
So the first step is
we use this extension.
It will start to create
OAuth tokens for me
automatically behind the scenes.
And I also have to
give access in IAM
that it can actually
invoke certain functions
or cloud run instances.
So it's not going to be on a
calling thing out of the box.
You still have IAM control
over what it can and can't do.
Now in the Apigee space, we
have to create these proxies.
So the first one we're going
to create this Cloud Run proxy.
And this is enterprise
stuff, so we're
using XML for configuration.
I guess that makes
it enterprise-ready.
So you see all this XML.
Don't die.
I almost did.
I had to come back to life.
So the first thing
here is this extension.
So the nice thing, though,
is there is a UI Composer.
You don't really have to
write all XML by hand.
So as you click
on this composer,
you can start to configure
some of these things.
So these things were
set up ahead of time.
Let me close this out.
And what you'll see here
is the configuration
for this extension.
I'm saying I would like to
use the Google Cloud Run
extension using the Google
authentication backend.
And then you give it
a couple of things.
So I know from
the documentation,
in order to call I
can't run service,
I had to give it this
particular audience.
So I know behind the
scenes, the extension
is going to use a Google
API, admit the OAuth token
using that particular audience.
And then it's going
to have the ability
to make that credential
available in this output
string.
So if you can see here, we
have this output string.
And this allows
me to then compose
a call that will extract that
out and set it into the header.
I'm going to show you that
configuration really quickly,
and then we're going
to invoke this.
So what I'm saying now in
this particular extension
is I want to set in
header before you actually
call my app.
You can actually see this
visual request preset of steps.
I can go to the authorization
header, reference
that Google Cloud
Run credential,
and it's going to inject
it in the header for me
automatically.
OK.
So the nice thing
is-- so this is
the thing that makes
Apigee dope in my opinion,
this whole little trace thing.
I was like, so I can
do that with Nginx.
Why are you showing
me this right now?
And then he did this.
He clicked on the
start trace thing,
and you can actually see
this complex configuration
come to life.
So if I hit this,
you can see that it's
going to actually move
through each of those steps,
and it's going to invoke
my particular function.
So you see here.
I'm going to walk through
what the output is.
It goes out to the extension.
I'm going to show
you some credentials.
Don't be hacking my service
while I'm on stage, OK.
Wait till later.
If you're on YouTube, this
won't work at this point.
This will be expired
by time you watch this.
All right.
Let me see if I can make
this a little bit bigger.
So down here, we're going
to have a bit of response
stuff happening here.
So this is actually going to--
I know its small the read here.
It's going to create
that OAuth token.
And it's going to
stored it in a way
that I can reference it
here when I set the header.
Let's move this back some.
Can I collapse this?
There we go.
All right.
We should really make
that-- all right.
So there we go.
So we have this access token.
So that access token is
going to be extracted out,
put it into a header,
and it's going
to be used to call the
service underneath.
And then you can
see here that it's
going to respond Cloud Run
just like on my local laptop.
So if I grab this, now
hitting the Apigee endpoint,
we can see that we hit
our particular backend.
OK.
So then what makes
Apigee relevant to having
multiple applications?
So let's try something
with Cloud Functions.
So this is using
Cloud Run, but we also
want to deploy something
to Cloud Function.
So if you never use
Cloud Functions,
this is a different take on
this whole service thing.
This is more of a
function as a service.
And Cloud Functions, you write
code that looks like this.
So you get rid of all the
server initialization,
and you just write your handler.
So this is also Go lang.
We just write a normal
Go HTTP handler.
You'll get your
request automatically.
And just like Cloud
Run, we also give you
an HTTP endpoint you can
hit without setting up
an API gateway.
But in this case, I also
want to make this also
a private function.
Now, this is deployed
using a different thing.
You don't build a
container first.
Here, you just use
a display command,
and it looks like this.
So I'm going to just be
in my source directory.
I am going to configure
this particular thing to run
as a specific service account.
And if you look
down here, I'm going
to grant the Apigee
services account the ability
to invoke this function.
All right.
So that's critical.
So the nice thing too
about Apigee extensions,
we also have an extension
just for Cloud Functions.
So all you have to do is
give it the particular set
of credentials, and
you tell the function
that you want to
have it invoked.
And you can skip a
lot of the boilerplate
that I did a little bit earlier.
But here's where I think
Apigee gets super powerful.
The other thing you might want
to do with APIs is each of them
will have some response.
Clients will hit your endpoint.
You'll respond however you want.
But there are cases where I see
people that are refactoring.
Maybe it's a monolith, and you
want to add a v0.2 endpoint.
In that case, sometimes
I'll build a small function
that adds a little bit.
And we can enhance the
particular response.
What you can do an
Apigee is I can actually
compose the response before
it goes back to the client.
So think about it this way.
I can deploy a Cloud Function.
It's going to have a
owns its own response.
I can take both
of those responses
and munge them into
their own output
before I send it
back to the client.
So we can walk you through that
configuration really quickly.
So we have another API proxy.
And this one's going
to be called Mashup.
So the endpoint here is going to
be this Cloud Function, Mashup.
Then we're going to
do here is we're going
to look at the deploy step.
And I have a bunch of these
steps that I have put in here.
So very similar
to the beginning,
we're going to use the extension
to grab the authentication
to call my first
service on Cloud Run.
And it's going to respond
with this runtime.
And then we're going to
hit the Lambda runtime--
or not Lambda runtime, the
Cloud Functions runtime.
And that extension is going to
call it the Cloud Functions.
And here, I'm just going
to tell it what region.
The name of the function
is also called Runtime.
And then I'm going
to take the response.
I'm going to show you
the configuration here.
So in this
configuration, you can
see that I'm going to
be able to reference
the response from the
two invocations previous.
So I call Cloud Run.
I'm going to take that output.
When I call Cloud Functions,
And here, instead of returning
a raw string to the client,
I'm going to return this JSON
payload that I'm composing here
without writing
any additional code
or hitting any other backend.
So what should happen here is
if I were to hit this endpoint--
So we'll go over
here to the overview.
If I were to hit this
endpoint, this mashup endpoint,
what we should see is
both of those functions
being called one by one.
And we should
compose the response
with both of their runtimes.
So you can see that there now.
So even with the
cold starts, you
can see the cold
starts are pretty fast
and both Cloud Run
and Cloud Functions.
And now, Apigee is
composing the response
from both of those
independent service calls
into something that I want
to do for the end user.
So it gives me the ability
to compose and do whatever
I want without additional code.
Now, there's one more thing
that we wanted to show you.
Where's the multi-cloud piece?
I typically don't say
things like multi-cloud.
There's multiple
environments where you
want to do some computation.
The hard parts about
multi-cloud-- or multiple
environments or multiple
cloud providers--
is composing the network
layer and the storage layer.
So what we'll see people do is
they'll just use best of breed.
So if you're using Amazon--
maybe you have a lot
of data in DynamoDB,
you're probably just
going to use Lambda.
If you have some stuff inside of
Google Cloud or cloud storage,
you're probably
just going to use
Cloud Run or Cloud Functions.
We're not forcing you to choose.
So we've also built an
extension for Lambda,
very similar to the other
centers that I had before.
When you write
your Lambda code--
if you've not written
any Lambda, good for you.
You're probably only
using Google services.
That's what we want you to do.
But in the Lambda world, here's
another Go app, very similar.
You write a function main.
You give it a handler,
and it's going to respond.
Now, the response is a little
bit different in the Lambda
world, and you'll see when
I munge them altogether.
But what we want
Apigee to do is also
compose this multiple
cloud thing for us.
So Apigee is our
central control plane.
It's our central entry point
for all of our clients,
but it has the ability to go
out to all the other endpoints
and aggregate all the responses.
So this is what we
mean by API management.
We don't have to leak all of
these details to our end users.
If you're in the organization
and some people want
to use one cloud provider,
and another team wants
to use a different
cloud provider,
you don't have to
argue too much.
You can normalize that
stuff on the Edge.
So we go over here to Lambda.
I'm going to show you
that I actually have
it deployed to Amazon's Lambda.
So it's a standard.
It's also called Runtime.
And then what we do is--
I'm going to show you the last
piece here in Apigee, where
we go to a different proxy.
Now, I could have done this
all in one single proxy,
but I broke it up, so you
can actually see the steps.
This particular path
is called multi-cloud.
So if I click on
multi-cloud, you'll
see the various calls
that I'm doing here.
I want to show you that
configuration here.
And you'll see-- hey,
don't be giving me
any errors in front of folks.
So the first one here, I'm
calling out to that Cloud
Function like we had before.
Then here, we're going to
be calling out to the Lambda
using the Lambda extension.
And the nice thing about
this Lambda extension--
just like I said up
before with Cloud Run--
I just give it a
set of credentials.
So you go to Amazon.
You create a set of credentials
that give it limited access
to invoke the Lambda function.
You don't need anything else.
And then I can refer
to that extension
here, and tell it very simply
the name of the function
is Runtime.
This is going to be a
synchronous request response.
And then I'm going to
take that response that
comes back from Lambda, and
hold it in this variable.
And again, just like I did
with a Cloud Functions,
I can take that
variable and then
use it as part of that
pipeline to munge the response.
So the only thing I'm doing
here is taking that response.
Scroll up.
I'm taking that response, and
I'm adding the Lambda response
to it.
So we should see an
additional response
in our particular array.
All right.
So let's go ahead
and hit this endpoint
to verify that everything works.
So we'll click on
this overview here.
And then we'll
grab this endpoint
to see if all three
can be invoked.
And we should get
that munge response.
Click here.
And we'll go back
to our browser.
So you see that
there's two there now.
We'll hit the
multi-cloud endpoint.
You can see now we've added
the response that comes back
from Amazon Lambda
as well using Apigee
to sit on top of all of those.
And it gives you choice
between any cloud provider,
any serverless stack that
you would like to use.
With that, I'd like to
end the particular demo.
Thank you.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL:
Thanks, Kelsey.
That was awesome.
You guys think?
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
So what you saw
Kelsey take us through
was something very powerful.
He mentioned a few
key capabilities
that we built
around what we call
it Apigee extensions, which
give you the ability to able--
it gives you the
ability to access
many cloud services, of course,
from Google Cloud Platform
and also from other
cloud providers as well.
So Apigee API
management platform
is a full lifecycle
API platform,
which is a key
component when you start
building your serverless
applications to ensure
that they are access
securely, they
have the right level
of controls in place,
and you have the right level of
operational visibility into it.
So if you start looking
at the different layers
of the platform, it starts
with the API runtime.
What Kelsey was demonstrating
today was the core enterprise
gateway and a set of
out-of-the-box policies,
which make it very easy to
take data from different kinds
of serverless apps, do some
composition, as you just saw.
The next level up is known
as the mediation engine.
And that provides some
of the core capability
around taking and orchestrating
data from different sources.
In this case, in
particular, Kelsey
demonstrated three different
types of extensions.
So two of the extensions were
actually just announced today
at this session, the Google
Authentication extension
and the Cloud
Function extensions,
which became available
generally today.
So those extensions
were a perfect example
of how you can take capabilities
from different serverless apps,
compose them.
Well, he took it a step further.
He also showcased the
Lambda extension--
which is available
within Apigee as well--
which you can use to go access
your serverless capability
that you're building on AWS.
As you go higher
up in the stack,
some area we didn't
cover today--
And I'll show some
screenshots real quick--
is the API monitoring and
analytics capabilities.
They become very
important in the realm
of once you have an API
program, which is driving--
and many of your
consumers are using API--
you want to be
able to ensure you
have the right level
of visibility, not
only from an operational
perspective--
of course, taking
care of things like
are my APIs performing well?
Do they have a lot
of errors suddenly?
Those kind of things--
to business metrics
around adoption.
I spoke about great,
you're building
serverless applications.
Who's using them?
Do you have the right level
of metrics on adoption?
And if not, some corrective
actions could be taken.
And the developer
ecosystem really
touches on the next level of how
do I really get the developers
access to these kind
of applications--
which are nothing
but API endpoints--
at some point in time?
So I'll just walk
you through a couple
of slides here real quick.
So this is an example
of the developer
portal, which is a key part of
the API management platform.
Using the constructs available
here, some of the API endpoints
that Kelsey was demonstrating
they weaken very quickly
and automatically generate
API documentation, which
can be rendered on a
developer portal that any
of the application developer--
who are the consumers of
this so it lists capability
that you're building--
can very quickly access.
They can try them out.
And more importantly,
they can register,
start using those capabilities.
So Developer Portal
becomes a key entry point
for the consumers of the
serverless applications.
And the last I'll going
to touch a little bit on,
the consumption aspect of it,
and monitoring and analytics.
So these dashboards give you
a very high-level entry point
into the different kinds
of metrics the API platform
captures out-of-the-box.
So just as you saw Kelsey
walking through three
different API proxies,
the moment API traffic
starts to bite through
the API proxies,
we collect over 200
different data points,
and have aggregations
of data sets, which
can be accessed for APIs, or
also access through the UI--
which Kelsey showed
some parts of it today.
So one example is the
dashboard on the top left.
We showed you the
overall engagement,
the overall traffic pattern.
What kind of API
calls are being made?
How many of them are in error?
So on and so forth.
And then you start to see some
other aspects of performance
latency analysis, and then the
ability to do custom reporting.
If none of the 20 or so
out-of-the-box dashboard's not
enough, you can actually go
build your own custom reports.
And this is a very
important feature
because many times APIs, once
they become front and center
of how you solve data,
they're different stakeholders
in the API program, such
as line of businesses.
If you're building
an order API, they
want to be able to know,
well, how many orders
are passing through--
office-specific amount--
for a specific region?
You don't have to go
out of the platform.
You can use custom report to
be able to just quickly report
that report, and give it to
the specific line of business
stakeholder who wants
it, versus having
to rely on getting data out,
using yet another platform
to build that out.
OK.
So with that, let's kind of
have Kelsey back over here.
Let's kind of summarize
some of the key takeaways.
And then we'll take any
questions after this.
So if you want to
come on over, Kelsey.
So just three high
level key takeaways.
I think we went through
a lot of things today,
but very quickly,
we spoke about some
of the serverless capabilities
that many of our customers
are adopting.
So clearly, it's very popular.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about multi-cloud
and your experience?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah,
so I think for me,
the serverless piece
is probably not
going to be one provider
platform specific.
I look at them as ways
to program in the cloud.
Sometimes you're
responding to events.
Something got
uploaded to a bucket.
Sometimes you just
have business logic
that you've had for
years, and you just
wanted to deploy
it via container.
And I decouple the problem.
So as much as I like these
fully integrated platforms,
I do like the ability
to compose, right?
I have a Unix background.
I would like to use an API
gateway for a certain thing.
I like to use different
runtimes for different things.
And what we talked about today
is the ability to compose.
What you saw in my demo
also is that I didn't have
to use Amazon's API gateway.
I didn't have to use a
load balancer in GCP.
And I was able to
pick and choose
how I wanted to orchestrate
my particular stack.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Perfect.
And then last but not the
least, as you hopefully
will have realized
today, API management
is a very vital function.
When you're building serverless
applications, the moment you
expand the reach of those
serverless applications
to your consumers, you want
to ensure they're secured.
Only the right level of
authorization is allowed.
In terms of access, you want
to have the right visibility.
So API management becomes
a very critical function
as you start to roll out
more and more serverless
applications.